landwirt ludwig soll aus habgier
zwanzigster september 2018 seine frau
walburga mit gül übergossen und damit
erstickt haben er handelte laut anklage
aus angst vor scheidung und verlust
seines vermögens der bauer soll zudem
immer wieder mit seiner frau um die
versorgung der 300 schweine auf dem 15
hektar hof im bayerischen donau ries
gestritten haben sein drei verteidiger
behaupten dagegen weilburger seit zum
putzen 6 in den glück in die güllegrube
gestiegen ausgerutscht und habe beim
aussteigen einen herzinfarkt erlitten
zwei der prominentesten rechtsmediziner
deutschland stritten vor gericht um die
wahrheit in diesem einmaligen fall
professor oliver paschel von der uni
münchen tendierte zu einem
gewaltverbrechen aber professor klaus
püschel aus hamburg favorisierte die
unfall theorie
der staatsanwalt forderte 13 einhalb
jahre haft die verteidigung freispruch
und heute vor der urteilsverkündung
konnte bild mit dem angeklagten sprechen
er schien da sehr entspannt
er erwartet einen freispruch weil er
unschuldig ist mir jetzt zugeschaltet
unser bild reporter jörg völkerling der
den prozess verfolgt hat ja was war am
ende dann das urteil
definitiv kein freispruch es wurden die
13 einhalb jahre hat die die
staatsanwaltschaft beantragt hatte
allerdings nicht wegen mordes sondern
wegen totschlags nicht wegen mordes weil
man kein motiv nachweisen konnte
die richterin sagte man aber auch sonst
kein motiv finden können also nicht den
besagten streit unterversorgung der
schweine man aber auch nicht gewusst ob
der landwirt dubio wirklich wusste dass
eine frau sich von ihm trennen bin
trotzdem rechnete die richterin mit ihm
wirklich verbal scharf ab sie nannte ihn
einen egoisten einen parteilosen
menschen dem es nur darum gegangen seine
eigene haut zu retten in diesem prozess
und er auch noch seine eigenen kinder
belogen haben das gericht musste
eingestehen dass man am ende dieses
indizienprozesses weder die tatwaffe
finden konnte mit der weilburger
niedergeschlagen wurde noch das gefäß
mit dem sie mit gülle übergossen wurde
das sei aber letztlich nicht
entscheidend weil man bisher dass die
polizei zunächst an diesem 20
september 2018 die tat nicht als
gewaltverbrechen erkannt hatte mutig
oder noch zwei tage aus seinem bau noch
schalten und walten konnte und demnach
auch eventuelle tatwerkzeuge beseitigen
oder putzen konnte zwei sehr bekannte
rechtsmediziner waren auch vor gericht
als zeugen geladen haben ihre gutachten
darüber abgeben ob es ein unfall war
oder eben ein gewaltverbrechen wie er
die richterin das eingeschätzt hat jetzt
noch mal genau erklärt warum sie eben
nicht glaubt dass es ein unfall war
sie hat sich den ausführungen von
professor oliver teschl von der
rechtsmedizin der uni wünschen
angeschlossen der vor gericht klar sagt
sei zwar nicht alles nachvollziehbar und
aufklärbar was genau passierte aber er
sagt das war keine medizinische ursache
die zum tod von walburga uhr führte und
regelrecht helmes hat die richterin das
andere
damit diese dann mit dem privat
gutachter professor klaus püschel aus
dem hohen norden abgerechnet der jetzt
also den bayerischen richter zeigen
wollte was eine harke ist
sie hatte fast süffisant aus einem
gutachten zitiert und da hieß es also er
habe behauptet dass walburga o quasi im
sturzflug auf den gülle mixa geflogen
sei danach in einem bewusstseins
getrübten 5 stand 28 cm tiefen die gülle
eingetaucht sei zwei minuten lang sieben
stücke gülle ein geschluckt habe aber
dabei nicht eingeatmet habe dann soll
sie sich aus eigener kraft wieder
hochgerappelt haben die leiter hoch
geklettert seien und sich quasi versucht
haben zu retten und sei dann erst
zusammengebrochen und da hat die
richterin gesagt das sei ja so abstrus
und so absurd dem könne man sich einfach
nicht anschließen
vielen dank jörg völkerling wir wollen
jetzt aber auch noch mal hören was die
verteidigung also nach der
urteilsverkündung zu sagen hatte als
verzweifelt der aufhänger sagt ich bin
unschuldig der opfinger sagt ich kann
nicht verstehen wie es zu diesem urteil
kommen kann
das gericht hat auch nach meiner meinung
mit einer absurden begründung alles was
entlastend ist beiseite gewischt und
sich lediglich auf die belastenden
punkte beschränkt der offinger
ist natürlich verzweifelt und zeigt
bitte helft mir ich habe nichts gemacht